The world has a way of rewarding the wrong kind of confidence.
Not the kind that bends with the wind, but the kind that stands so rigid it could cut glass only to shatter under the slightest pressure.
Nassim Taleb called it itrogenics, the harm caused by the healer.
A surgeon who overtreats a minor wound leaves scars worse than the original injury.
And so it is with the ego.
We chase self-esteem like it's a cure, but it's the disease, the truly miserable.
Don't suffer from a weak ego.
No, they've built something far more dangerous, a fragile one, hard as diamond.
Yes, but diamonds crack under the right hammer.
Most life advice tells you to believe in yourself, a noble lie if ever there was one.
For the maven, this is the first step toward a magnificent collapse.
If you staked your identity on being grand, then every misstep isn't a lesson, it's an apocalypse.
90% of your energy goes into defending the illusion, 10% into living, and what's left?
A hollow shell, polished to a shine, but empty inside.
Here's how you construct it.
First, declare yourself an expert before you've earned the title.
The moment you do, you've trapped yourself.
Questions become heresy.
Ignorance is no longer an option.
The iatrogenics of the eagle have begun.
Every correction feels like a betrayal, every doubt a personal attack.
You built a fortress, and now you must guard it with your life.
Then, adopt the defensive crouch.
Feedback isn't constructive, it's sabotage.
A typo in your work?
Not a typo.
An assassination attempt.
By refusing to bend, you ensure your psyche never learns to adapt.
Anti-fragility?
That's for the weak.
You're building a porcelain identity, and the world is full of clumsy hands.
When insecurity gnaws at you, don't look inward.
Project it outward.
Lazy?
Your colleague is the problem.
Unproductive?
The system is rigged.
Keep your internal image pristine while the world outside rots.
And never, never change your mind.
To do so is to admit your past self was a fraud.
Stay stubborn.
Stay principled.
Even as the iceberg looms closer.
The result?
A diamond in the dark.
Magnificent to behold.
Yes, but rigid.
Untouchable.
And utterly alone.
No one can reach you.
Which means, no one can help you either.
You've perfected self-enclosure.
A masterpiece.
Consider the residence log, May 6th.
The subject had it all, success, admiration, the perfect facade, but beneath it all, a terror,
the fear of being found out.
The iatrogenics of the ego had done its work.
Every victory was a lie.
Every compliment a debt.
And in the end, what did it leave him with?
Not fulfillment.
Not peace.
Just the slow, creeping realization that he'd spent his life building a house of cards and
the wind was coming.
A tree that does not bend in the wind shall eventually become firewood.
Be the firewood.